this week 70,000 weirdos will descend on
the Nevada desert to bump uglies roll
around in filth and worship Moloch we
will analyze how millenials favorite
pagan orgy became America's most popular
religious event then we will explore why
everybody is suddenly transgender maybe
me included maybe I really am Rachel
Maddow and we will blame our debauched
sexual culture on British royalty it
seems fitting historically speaking
finally a primary night recap as CNN
fills our leftist ears Tumblr's to the
brim I'm Michael Knowles and this is the
Michael Knowles show those tears were a
little hot I just burned my tongue a
little it's still hot from last night
they're hot from the Florida primaries
so we have a lot to talk about today
this is one of my favorite topics
bizarre radical sex so we'll get into
that as well as the politics before we
do that though let's talk about a
wonderful sponsor cold keeps this is
look if I ever want to get a chance of
picking up those filthy hippie girls
over at Burning Man I got to keep my
hair baby this is the only thing I got
working I'm not exactly an Adonis or a
Hercules statue or something like that
so you got to keep your hair and keeps
us the way to do it it is designed for
guys who want to stop hair loss with
their scientific and affordable approach
managed entirely on keeps calm keeps is
the easiest way to stop hair loss before
it's too late yes it really works it
offers the only two fda-approved hair
loss products clinically proven to keep
the hair you have
there is no BS there's no you know
magical spells this is just science and
it's completely safe these are the
generic versions of medications that
have been around for a while now they're
cheaper they're easier to get and keeps
makes it very easy just do it guys it
costs very little for five minutes now
and a dollar a day or less than a dollar
a day you will never have to worry about
hair loss again most people don't know
hair loss can set in twenty five thirty
five years old
stop it let's stop it right now it's
very inexpensive you're gonna thank
yourself later a sign up takes less than
five minutes it's ten to thirty five
bucks a month now you get your first
month three free rather thanks to me
that's a lot of sounds but you should
thank me because don't say never did
nothing for you stuff your loss today
the easy way with Keith
goto keeps calm / cough FAC OB f EF e ki
EEP s.com / cough fa Co V Fe Fe that's a
free month of treatment keeps calm /
cough FA Co V Fe Fe keeps here today
hair tomorrow dirty hippie girls at
Burning Man the next day today a
tomorrow and then you've got a Burning
Man the next day so today's show is
gonna be all about sex and this is not
just your average orgy because I was
actually hoping you know they give me
really terrible assignments here I've
got to go to Hollywood Boulevard I've
got to watch the movie about Barack
Obama I've got to do this I've got to do
that I just said can you please send me
to the weird millennial hippie sex
ritual can that be my one no they won't
let me go so I had to look at it from
afar but that's possibly okay because I
realized that Burning Man is not just a
weird festival electronic music druggy
dance have sex with dirty people thing
it is America's largest religious event
that's not hyperbole
they basically admit it themselves and
they get a lot of people to show up
70,000 people will come this year what
they do is indistinguishable from
ancient pagan rituals from even modern
pagan rituals it all has Center and
religious longing we will analyze all of
those things because I think basically
the people who are participating in it
don't really know what they're doing
which is often the case for those who
are not familiar with it and also
because I want to see very misguided hot
young millennial girls dance can we see
a clip of the live stream from Burning
Man
[Music]
[Music]
you know you know this is sort of true
of all perversion but when you look at
this for those of you who couldn't see
the clip you should subscribe to daily
wire so you could it's this electronic
dance music Boombah Boombah it's got
this weird vaguely middle eastern indian
sounding music and it's got what appear
to be hot women wearing weird clothes
and like skull masks and animal masks
and weird chains and stuff and like all
perversion when you hear about it in
theory it sounds kind of titillating you
think oh that might be kind of it then
you'll look at it and it's just you
mostly horrifying and then this is true
this is always true a perversion I don't
just mean sexual perversion perversion
in general and this is the case of
Burning Man but when you look at it if
this were displaced if this were in some
ancient druidic compound somewhere and
you saw people jumping around to this
with these weird beats in strange
sensual attire and like big animal heads
on their head you'd say oh yeah they're
that's a pagan ritual of course but for
some reason when we say to Burning Man
we say wow how modern how new there's
nothing new Under the Sun there's
certainly nothing new about this if
anything the only new thing was
Christianity which managed to persist
throughout the culture for I don't know
what 1500 years or so and and now we're
seeing what happens when you pull pull
that back so just a little background on
what Burning Man is Burning Man was
created in 1986 it was founded by these
hippy artist types over in San Francisco
and it was a summer solstice festival
where the misses where it gets weird the
founders say they spontaneously burn
an eight-foot-tall wicker man and a
smaller wicker dog spontaneously and I
don't know where you spontaneously come
across gigantic wicker people and then
you know just naturally have the idea
that they have to set them on fire
incinerate that something but anyway
that's their story so they did that it
was on the Solstice so it already has a
kind of ritualistic aspect to it a
vaguely religious or spiritual aspect to
it and then it grew every year and it
grew and then they started doing bigger
and bigger ones and eventually by 2014 I
think the statue became a hundred and
five feet tall and it they did it in
Nevada in the Nevada desert it attracted
more and more and more people now we're
up to 70,000 people and it's taken on
this decidedly spiritual tone so this I
just went to the Burning Man website
they have their own Burning Man journal
they have their own Burning Man
philosophy I mean ever be a person I
talk to I say have you begun to burn him
and even to Burning Man they'll say no I
haven't been but oh man a friend of mine
he's like religious about it so like I
know he's religious about it because
it's a religious experience of course
that's the whole point and we'll explain
why cuz I actually don't really blame
the very misguided Millennials who are
going to this I don't blame them for
going they're going because there's an
absence of meaning in their lives we can
we can talk about that a little later I
just went to the Burning Man website and
I wanted to see what's this about what
are they writing about what's on their
blog this is what's up this year they're
they're talking about participating in
ritual participatory ritual and this is
a the quotes that they have at the top
of this page they say consider the
Golden Spike the Golden Spike every year
they go into the desert they clamp down
this golden spike in a ritual quote each
year the recreation of Black Rock City
from the empty desert is celebrated by
driving a gold painted length of steel
into the playa at the spot where the
Burning Man will stand and from which
point the entire city is surveyed
another quote that they have out there
is this may be the essential genius of
Burning Man out of nothing we created
everything and if that obviously that
isn't religious talk then nothing is
that's a Genesis
I mean that's the first first lines of
Genesis are out of nothing we create
something and that's what they think
they're doing obviously they're not
creating something out of nothing
they're taking a bunch of hippies and
getting weird and dirty around a desert
for a few days and then leaving and
leaving it and leaving a lot of exhaust
and pollution in the air so it's not
something out of nothing it's something
out of something but that is the
religious component of it and it gets it
gets even weirder they go on in this
blog post because they have these
different rituals that are developed
over time so they've temples they have
they have an orgy dome more on that in a
bit that was where I requested to go for
my assignment I said now you're probably
not allowed in and so it said quote this
year the Burning Man will reside in a
temple that is dedicated to the golden
spike every space and turning the entire
grid of our collective home derives from
this singular point in space hold on one
sec I'll go on we will mark this spot
with an omphalos a sculpture that will
represent the navel of our world
aligning with the spine of Burning Man
this will create an axis that continues
upward emerging high above the temple as
a gilded spire the sculpture of the man
will stand directly on the ground and it
will be like every one of us he will
live in a house he will inhabit a home
and should you wish to visit him you
must get up close and personal
participants will witness the figure in
intimate detail including every beveled
edge and compound joint our man crew has
employed in fashioning its body now for
those of you in my audience who are not
very high on drugs already this might
not make a lot of sense fortunately I
assume most of you are on a lot of drugs
at the inner psychedelics or something
like that but this is very strange talk
and a lot of it sounds vaguely Christian
or vaguely Jewish or Zen of the temples
and the man being the sort of avatar of
spirituality and the you know youth that
you see these kind of religious
parallels but everything is a little off
everything is a little bit wrong
so where it actually comes from the
founder
don't grant this but it's obviously true
is from this ancient druidic ritual
which was the Wickerman ritual they say
they hadn't heard of it they said it's
blah blah blah but it's almost the exact
same thing the ancient druids would
create a giant man out of wicker and
they would burn him and set him on fire
as a sacrifice every year Julius Caesar
wrote about this in his commentaries on
the Gallic war so it happened every year
it had fallen into disuse until modern
paganism came around what they call this
is an act of radical self-expression
they're saying they build this 100 foot
tall man every year a change is 40 foot
20 foot hundred foot call it a 100 foot
tall man and they burn it he's in
different positions during the year some
there was one word there they're in a
real sensual position where it's clearly
people about to you know get down and
bump some uglies and other times it's
this giant man and they set him on fire
they call it a radical act of
self-expression but it's not an act of
self-expression that's an act of
self-destruction right that's an act of
self negation it's it's self
annihilation it's a sacrifice why I mean
when we read the Bible when we read of
ancient texts Gilgamesh whatever you see
plenty of people going out into deserts
and burning idols and having weird
rituals around them but for some reason
when they do it we look at it we say oh
that's so weird who would ever do that
why are they doing that that doesn't
make any sense
and then people do this exact same thing
on an even larger scale and we say oh
it's it's a music festival oh it's you
know it's just a bunch of hippies going
out and whatever it's really really
strange so it's not it doesn't just stop
there though it doesn't just stop at the
ritual it doesn't just stop at the
history they have ten principles the
doctrine of Burning Man and here are
those principles it's kind of
interesting because they they seem
similar to two principles that we would
have the first is radical inclusion so
everybody can come everybody's allowed
to come into a Burning Man
the other is gifting so you have to like
give people stuff you can't you can't
use money when you're in Burning Man and
then this is my favorite one the third
principle is decommodification so saying
no money money is bad we don't want to
turn anything into a commodity
Oh your ticket your ticket costs $1,000
but yeah but man after that it's totally
there's no money these tickets cost
anywhere from 200 bucks to $1,200 the
parking fee is 80 or 90 bucks but then
they say but no money no money and this
is always the case with these things
you'll hear people say I'm sure the vast
majority if not all of the people who go
there would say this isn't religious
this isn't a religious thing that's
crazy
but then they do religious things
they'll say oh this isn't about money
this isn't about commodities but then
they pay $1,200 to go they don't even
know it's happening and this we do this
all the time we don't know when we're
doing these things this is what makes
idolatry so pernicious this is what
makes it so dangerous you don't know
when it's happening then they talk about
radical self-reliance radical
self-expression communal effort civic
responsibility leaving no trace this is
a silly one too because so much of this
is about nature worship so much of the
modern lefty mindset is environmentalism
nature worship we're killing the earth
whatever that means
they say you have to leave no trace you
have to commit the zero waste and they
really believe this but that is
impossible if you if you exist in the
world you create waste and it's
obviously absurd you have 70,000 people
coming out there on airplanes planes
trains and automobiles driving doing a
bunch of drugs like these things don't
cost nothing to do they don't they expel
a lot of carbon dioxide they expel Cupp
pollutants into the environment but
still they pretend there's this
mythology of it all then it says
participation and then the last one is
immediacy they say no idea can
substitute for this experience and even
here is a very important religious point
someone asked the other day in the
mailbag about Gnosticism the idea that
there's a secret knowledge that leads to
salvation and Gnosticism is a heresy
because you have to do things you have
to put things into your body religion
requires you to participate in it
they're saying exactly the same thing
here Burning Man is saying exactly the
same thing they say you need to
participate in the ritual you need to
put your whole body into it and so what
does this mean practically practically
speaking what this means is sex drugs
and bizarre spirituality but that's what
it exists for this brings us
the most titillating part of Burning Man
which is something called the orgy dumb
the orgy dome is not the only place at
which to have an orgy at Burning Man but
it is the most famous place I'd had to
try to find a PG family-friendly clip
about the orgy dome which took up most
of my morning but here is the the most
PG rated one I could find to explain and
give you a little bit of a tour of what
the orgy dome looked like this was a
number of years ago but what the orgy
dome looks like at Burning Man hello our
Burning Man theme camp has been heating
up the playa with the Hawks Xfire gym
and our famous 24-hour air conditioned
orgy dome for ten years that's right we
have been providing an intimate place
for lovers in Black Rock City for a
decade the dome is open to couples and
more soms
looking for a safe place to love let's
face it tents get messy and dirty far
from romantic and if you are sharing an
RV somehow a dome full of sexy strangers
is easier than trying to be intimate
with roommates around that's where we
come in when you and your partner enter
the dome you're greeted by us and we
make sure you know simple safety rules
and given a sanitary towel you remove
your dusty shoes before entering the
orgy dome space where you will find soft
lighting mattresses and couches on soft
carpet and lovely drapery along the
walls that just that voice just that
voice alone makes you think like I get
out of here you get out go away yep that
lady sounds like she's been rode hard
and put away wet I'm that is a reference
but that is an old farm analogy that is
not a dirty analogy get your minds out
of the gutter I know that you were just
watching a clip about an orgy dome so I
forgive you for your your gutter
thinking but there really is this you
hear that boys like hey I've been having
a great time at the orgy dome oh yeah I
couldn't be happier I'm really
flourishing
people can love here on disgusting
mattresses there is it has been
estimated and this estimate comes from
four or five years ago that 5000 people
over 5,000 people have gone into the
orgy dome
can you even imagine how disgusting that
place is for those of you who can't
watch
maybe you shouldn't subscribe maybe this
is a great argument for listening to the
show I'm on audio but for those who
couldn't see it it's just filthy
mattresses underneath a tent with a with
a lady who sounds like she's smoked six
packs of cigarettes a day for 30 years
telling you how lovely and wholesome and
enjoyable it is it doesn't seem that
enjoyable does it but the aspect here
that really makes me not want this
assignment even if I could have gotten
it is the everybody is filthy there's no
cleanliness to this thing when you get
there you're encouraged to kind of just
roll around in the dirt because there
aren't a lot of showers now if there are
any showers at all people clean off with
a little bit of water or soapy water or
something
and just people lying around doing drugs
in sweltering heat in the Nevada desert
for days and days and days and then
frolicking around a filthy orgy dome
where 5000 people have been before you
if that is not enough to get you to run
to church right now get down on your
knees beg forgiveness and never leave I
don't know what is but this is the
promise of Burning Man the promise of
Burning Man is that you're entering
another world in this world you have to
clean yourself and work and like read
books and you know wake up on time and
take care of people and have
accountability and cook dinner and all
these things in at Burning Man it's
another world it's a different world you
don't have to bathe if you don't have to
do anything you can roll around in the
dirt you can have sex with whomever you
like it's long you know I mean
presumably you have to like get a chick
to like you but I don't know if
everybody's hopped up on ecstasy I don't
know how hard that is then you you know
listen to electronic music even that
aspect it's not like you're listening to
Brahms and Beethoven you're listening to
music that speaks to what Aristotle and
Plato would call the base passions that
is just all a base it's all percussion
it's all speaking to that part of you
which is rhythmic and tribal so you're
just kind of moving and going with the
flow man it's another world and this is
what's drawing so many people now we can
get really into the two why I don't feel
bad actually sort of feel bad and I
don't really judge these hippies because
they're in a culture that encourages
and where they think they don't have any
other choice there's another world
people are always looking for another
world there's a reason why drug use is
so high up it's not simply escapism from
the quotidian it's looking for
transcendence it's people who everyone
who has ever taken acid were mushrooms
or even I guess even edibles or smoked
pot or something they're looking for an
experience that is not of this world and
the reason for that is all human beings
longed for another world we feel like
we're not at home in this world this is
the traditional Christian ethos we are
pilgrims in this world we are made for
another world which is heaven CS Lewis
writes about this beautifully CS Lewis
basically translating Thomas Aquinas for
modernity he says quote creatures are
not born with desires
unless satisfaction for these desires
exists a baby feels hunger well there is
such a thing as food a duckling wants to
swim well there is such a thing as water
men feel sexual desire well there's such
a thing as sex if I find myself in
myself a desire which no experience in
this world can satisfy the most probable
explanation is that I was made for
another world we all this is the
argument from desire basically all of
mankind has a desire for God a desire
for transcendence and therefore there
there must be a satisfaction to that
long unless the world is one cruel joke
as cynics think it is as nihilists think
it is then there is a satisfaction for
that longing that's what the people are
looking for it burning and that's what
people go for and you see this in the
report they do every year they do the
afterburn report over who goes to this
thing and and who is who is showing up
the median age at Burning Man is thirty
to thirty four its Millennials slightly
on the older end of millennial but it's
it's people who have had been working
day jobs and don't don't feel fulfilled
in that they're looking for an escape
they're looking for some way to regress
into childhood to become childish or
childlike and to transcend the everyday
these are not total poor degenerate
people that's what you might think you'd
think it's like all just homeless people
showing up right to be yours
the bowline to screw around and do a lot
of drugs but that isn't what it is it's
what they actually found is that people
are disproportionately educated at
Burning Man they're they're people who
disproportionately have college degrees
or even graduate degrees I think the
majority of people who attend Burning
Man certainly the majority have a BA and
I think the majority have even a
master's 44 percent of them almost half
of Burning Man makes over $100,000 per
year that's pretty high
so it's all of these yuppies these young
urban professionals over credentialed
probably under educated looking for
something that is not being satisfied in
their daily lives the the breakdown of
their religious views is pretty
interesting fifteen point nine percent
of people who go to Burning Man say that
they're religious so the vast majority
eighty over eighty four percent of
people at Burning Man say they're not
religious okay this might explain why
they go there about twenty four percent
say they're atheist one percent say that
they're deus sixteen percent say they're
agnostic and then another eight percent
say I don't know which is very funny
because I agnostic means I don't know so
you can add those two together you know
it's like 24 percent almost a quarter of
people there or agnostic and then the
big number the lion's share almost half
of the people who go to Burning Man do
you know what they are you know what I'm
gonna say I don't even need to say it do
I
on the count of three ready one they are
one two three spiritual but not
religious as you who got it 100 percent
of people got it spiritual but not
religious and this is something that is
really pernicious I've talked about this
in other episodes I've talked about
there was a great book on this and
immoveable feast which I recommend you
read it's on this problem of spiritual
but not religious spiritual but not
religious defines our generation it
defines Millennials it's people who want
the nice aspects of religion they want
that natural human longing for God to be
fulfilled but they don't wanna have to
do anything about it they don't wanna
have to do anything that they don't want
to do they want you know you read the
Bible and you see the Jews wandering in
the desert and then Moses goes away for
five seconds and they immediately start
worshiping a golden
you see you idiots what are you
delivered you out of the desert go but
long you forgot he's giving you man he's
giving you this he's giving you that and
this yeah but I don't want to do any of
the rules I don't want to follow the
rules I don't want to I want God to come
to me on my terms I'm spiritual but not
religious I'm not that interested in God
I'm very interested in me and I want
transcendence spiritual but not
religious that's the lion's share of
them so another interesting question
they say do you belong to a religion or
religious denomination 71% say no
twenty-eight point eight percent say yes
so all of the people who say any
religion paganism this isn't that is
Unitarian whatever a better quarter of
people say yes we belong to some
religion so clearly there's a
misunderstanding here with regard to
religion we've got to wrap this up but
I'd really want to get to this point I
think some of you might still be looking
at me and say Michael you're just you're
being hyperbolic you're misunderstanding
Burning Man Burning Man
it's just people having fun it's just
kids stupid kids going out and having
fun first of all they're not kids
they're 34 years old and second of all
they're probably not stupid they're
actually disproportionately over
educated or at least over credentialed
but this is religion it's not III think
that people are misunderstanding
paganism here it's not that we're
misunderstanding Burning Man or that
we're misunderstanding the nature of
Burning Man it's that people are
misunderstanding the nature of paganism
they always pretend it's something other
like that they would never do if you
read about paganism in any of the
ancient myths or any of the ancient
histories or the Bible or whatever it's
this very different thing so I can't
what is what is pal come on that's
that's what old people did before they
had science before like us they had sign
now we have science so we can't have
paganism of course you can in many ways
scientific naturalism has created a new
paganism it's the same idol worship of
nature that the Hittites engaged and
it's the same idol worship of nature
that a pre-christian non-jewish people
engaged in and the main religious right
here is the main religious right of
those ancient people the the weirdo
dirty hippies at Burning Man
or engaging in the same central
religious Rite which is sacred
prostitution even that phrase people are
unfamiliar with that sacred prostitution
is a major religious form you see ting
Gilgamesh the
actually in Gilgamesh who was the name
is a sham Hut the sacred prostitutes
sham Hut is largely responsible for
creating civilized man for civilizing
this wild man and making him a member of
society it's this sacred prostitute
Judah has sex with a sacred prostitute
in Genesis the sacred prostitute Tamar
Herodotus describes the ancient
Babylonians as requiring their women to
undergo a sacred prostitute ritual where
they go to kingdoms of the richer
temples of the love goddess and have sex
with men willingly for money or not for
not with money the Code of Hammurabi the
oldest legal code in the world protects
sacred prostitutes specifically the
ancient Hittites the ancient Sumerians
the Corinthians
everybody had sacred prostitutes as a
central aspect of their society and
actually the Phoenician cities multiple
Phoenician cities had these sacred
prostitutes within the Roman Empire
until Emperor Constantine put a stop to
it does anyone remember where
Constantine comes into play Constantine
is the Emperor who broadens the appeal
of Christianity throughout the Roman
Empire decriminalizes Christianity
throughout the empire it's only at that
point it's only at the advent of
Christianity on a wide scale that these
ideas of sacred prostitution these
ancient rites go away so what do we
think is it just that the all of these
ancient peoples were weird and bizarre
and crazy and these hippies in the
desert are just weird and bizarre and
crazy no of course I'm not saying that
at all what I'm saying is there is
something essential in human nature that
tends toward these things that tends
toward paganism that tends toward nature
worship that tends toward sacred
prostitution and the idolatry of
sensuality and the the idolatry of
sensuality and there is something
different in religion that comes into
place in Christian religion in Judaism
which says no to that it says do not
follow your basest instincts your base
passions and your human nature do
something higher use your mind use your
intellect use your consciousness use
your will to aim toward something higher
which is the true God not these nature
spirits that you're worshipping but the
true God this is the story of the Bible
it's the story of the new the Old
Testament and the people constantly
revert back to their old ways their
natural ways that's what's happening at
Burning Man the people at Burning Man
think that they're forming a new society
a new city out of nothing creating a new
thing out of nothing in this with this
novel idea of a barter system as though
the barter system didn't predate the
modern financial institutions that
didn't create our modern system of
currency and finance this new
spirituality this new sensuality there's
nothing new about it it is simply the
base instinct even the new music we
think this is a new music like Bach is
old and dubstep is new not that that is
an obvious that is exactly flipped there
is nothing in the world that is older
than dubstep or EDM or modern electronic
percussion music that's the oldest form
of music in the entire world the newest
form of music is the music that goes
higher than that has harmony that has
melody that has a sophistication it
might be 300 years old it's still the
newest music in the entire world and
what is happening as a result of this
then I've got to say goodbye to Facebook
and YouTube this is having practical
effects throughout our culture it's not
confined to a random desert in Nevada
it's going out around the world this
year Americans are diagnosed with a
record number of sexually transmitted
diseases I don't want to sound like a
prude on all of this okay I'm actually
not a prude there's a time and a place
for everything in that place is college
or Burning Man I guess but the this is
really becoming a social problem you
have to call it out for what it is we
have the a record number of STDs
diagnosed in the u.s. 2.3 million people
will be diagnosed with an STD this year
that's the fourth year in a row that
we've broken a record this trend is
getting absurdly high and we're talking
about chlamydia we're talking about
gonorrhea we're talking about syphilis
specifically in the gay community
gay guys are spreading syphilis didn't
we get rid of syphilis a hundred years
ago shouldn't this have been gone a long
time ago no it's making a comeback
paganism our base instincts are making a
back baby along with syphilis because
people are having unprotected sex
they're having unprotected sex with
multiple partners they're having
unprotected sex with multiple partners
at the same time in the orgy dome in the
middle of the desert in Nevada the CDC
is very concerned about this the CDC is
issuing warnings they don't understand
why this is happening we we're modern we
have science we are using our reason
aren't we not at all there is a great
quote from Chesterton he said the madman
is not the guy who loses his reason he's
the guy who loses everything except for
his reason people in that desert are
using their reason but they're not using
anything else they're not grounding it
in first principles not grounding it in
traditions and faith and culture they're
going with their base passions and where
they're illogic leads them in that and
this this has led to some absurdity in
the me2 movement you've now got a porn
actress Jenny blye
hardcore porn actress who is complaining
because she was treated like a piece of
meat on a porn set we'll get into that
in a second we'll get into the
transgender social contagion have this
all of this social stuff plays a role in
our transgender obsession it's playing a
role in screwing up our kids we can
blame Charles and Diana for that and
we've got to talk about politics you got
to talk about last night's big primary
night I can't get to any of that before
I say goodbye to you on Facebook and
YouTube I've probably already said
goodbye to you or probably already
censor there's another wave of
censorship that came out this morning so
if you're on Daley we're calm thank you
you help keep the lights on and khofifah
in my cup if you are not over there go
to Daley wire you get me the under
claiming show the ben shapiro show you
get to ask questions in the mailbag
that's coming up tomorrow get your
questions in and you also get to ask
questions in the conversation which is
coming up with the big boss Ben none of
that matters get the leftist tears
tumblr this is the only way especially
if you're going to that orgy dome in the
middle of Nevada you're gonna want to
you're gonna have to take the leftist to
it leave the leftist tears in put just a
dash of soap the salt will help scrub
and clean you off before you go into the
orgy dome and it'll bubble up and fizzle
be very good for you so leftist here
they have so many uses don't they go to
daily where that come we'll be right
back
[Music]
this is an amazing headline I feel bad
for the woman her name is Jenny blye or
bligg or something and she's got a meet
to complaint when she was on a porn set
which is that she said she was treated
like a piece of meat
now is there even a joke to be made
about that that is the definition of a
porn set as you're treating your body as
a piece of meat and but I do feel kind
of bad for her she says by the way that
the director of the porn movie who she
says groped her came up and like grabbed
her while he was filming copped a little
feel you know this guy hasn't the name
John staliano and she said that he
didn't know he didn't know that he
wasn't supposed to do that but he should
have asked my permission but she's an
actress in a porno movie and you know
last time I checked those movies don't
that's not like asking permission every
step of the way I don't think that's how
that works
this is a real social contagion because
in this case porn is a fantasy right
porn is creating a fantasy and marketing
it to people who are desiring a fantasy
they're desiring a longing for sexuality
in that outlet is a cheap and easy way
out but it's it's probably not the most
gratifying one this is a fantasy and
other sexual fantasies are spreading as
well there was a study out of Brown
University that transgender
identification is a social contagion
that there is this spreads around
socially the study identified groups of
young adults who said that they had 50%
or that the majority of them had trans
identifying people within their small
group of friends over 50% and this is
statistically impossible this is 70
times the expected average here of
people who have the legitimate social
confusion or a psychological confusion
about their biological sex this is much
much higher than average so clearly this
is spreading in a social way it's
spreading because it's being
mainstreamed by the culture the study
also found that 62% of people
identifying with gender dysphoria had a
some psychological disorder before they
identified as a member of the other sex
so before they got confused about their
sex they had some other mental illness
going on and almost 50% 48% of these
people had it
dramatic event before they had gender
confusion that's bullying that sexual
assault and that's also divorce so
divorce is listed in there very
politically incorrect you're not allowed
to say it
Brown was forced to pull this study
Brown you know it's amazing they they
said in there a note about this they
send on a big note to everybody they
said we believe in academic freedom but
they always do that
it was comic but and then they say we
believe in academic freedom but we don't
really high and then they pulled the
study because it's politically incorrect
but this is the part we can't talk about
this is I was mentioning this at the end
of the show yesterday the politically
incorrect thing here is that we're not
allowed to say that perhaps our social
or physical ailments are gender
confusion the high increase in suicide
the high increase in drug addictions in
alcohol abuse in opioid abuse in
self-harm in all of these things maybe
that has something to do with our Sikh
culture if that's what this Brown study
is saying it's saying people who
experience abuse who experience traumas
who experience the divorce of their
parents are more likely to have these
mental problems including gender
confusion this brings us down to this
day in history which was actually
yesterday in history in 1996 Prince
Charles and Princess Diana got a divorce
they divorced publicly in this BK this
was in the news I remember this as a kid
it was in the news constantly people
were so neurotic about the Princess
Diana and whatever and they what they
effective that was so mainstreaming of
divorce now look you the Church of
England was founded because Henry the
8th you know wanted to get a divorce and
chop off the heads of his wives and have
a male son or whatever so we can say
that Charles and Diana were better
spouses to one another than Henry the
8th perhaps but you've got to remember
Edward the eighth abdicated in the early
20th century he had to abdicate the
throne because he wanted to marry a
divorced woman there was a real sense of
seriousness about marriage in the early
20th century that fell apart at the end
of the 1990s all of this is connected
all of this is connected because what
Charles and Diana were just symbols on
TV you
the aristocracy in the Royal Palace of
what was happening around the world
which is that divorce was exploding
especially in the nineties many if not
most of my friends have parents who were
divorced divorce
was everywhere and some people made it
out just fine or relatively fine from
divorce a lot of people I know were run
over by it it's an aspect of a sexually
irresponsible culture and again I'm not
talking about the time in a place for
everything you know I'm not saying that
you know when you're a kid you can't
experiment or whatever be a little loose
but when you're the Prince of Wales when
you're correct when you're British
royalty when you're on the throne when
you have children don't do it you have
to put other people before yourselves
and that sexual selfishness really does
seem to go hand-in-hand with all of
these social problems with all of these
psychological problems and and all of
these health problems they're all
connected to this speaking of bad
parenting I've got to go in a few
minutes so I do want to get through
these political things we can talk more
about weird sex at another time
speaking of bad parenting there was a
student who assaulted another student in
class because he was wearing a make
America great again hat you have to
listen to how the parent reacted to this
take it away video shows some of the
tension inside this high school
classroom the teacher trying to subdue a
fired up seventeen-year-old senior I
don't agree with you know grabbing
someone's hat and and verbally talking
to him that way but as far as the issue
being brought up that maybe this is
something that needs to be not just it
needs to be brought up it's another one
of these buttheads drew calls them the
butt heads they say one thing and then
they negate what they just said because
they use the word but afterwards says
well I didn't you know I didn't like
that but don't wear the hat are you
gonna you know you're gonna get in
trouble we're gonna hit you a really
awful parenting and this is this is why
Trump is popular so in our last minutes
here I do want to cover the the
primaries last night because they do
show very good signs for November for
Republicans say that cautiously anything
could happen but these are pretty good
signs
so in Arizona martha mcsalley beat out
Kelly Ward and Joe Arpaio I like all of
those people they all seem very nice
mcsalley it was a good candidate though
probably a safe candidate when we get
into the general election and then the
real story for Donald Trump is in
Florida where Ron de santis won his
primary he was running against Adam
Putnam Adam Putnam was the favorite he
was killing it in the polls he was
totally gonna beat DeSantis then Trump
comes out and endorses Ron DeSantis Ron
DeSantis wins in a landslide
they couldn't even Putnam said he said
we can't catch up there it's so hard to
catch up this shows us that even in a
swing state even in a place that really
matters Florida really really matters in
2020 president Trump's word is very
popular we know this as approval ratings
are very high he he's a popular guy
everything is going very well under his
presidency so the left is furious about
this here is the I love this i gobbled
this up I took the lid off my tumbler
and just put it underneath the faucet
here is the mainstream media freaking
out over Trump's popularity last week
was a tidal wave of bad news for this
presidency and this president and his
approval ratings stayed the same so I
wonder I mean if that's not gonna move
the needle is this John McCain thing
gonna move the needle and and forgive me
for being skeptical because I was under
the impression as was most people that
when Donald Trump came out and said he
was not a war hero he likes the guys
that don't get caught back in 2015 that
people would care and when I went out
and I talked to Republican voters they
didn't care at all the Republicans don't
care but 43% is both a very high number
when you realize that that many people
are so deluded as to believe this guy's
a good president but it's also a pretty
low number you know and a lot of
independents have left Donald Trump they
voted for him in 2016 they're not going
to vote for him again they have much
more in common with John McCain so you
have to draw a distinction between
hardcore Republicans who as Trump said
he could shoot somebody on Fifth Avenue
they still support him and a much really
larger group of people who go in
different directions depending on the
election 88% of Republicans still
support him you know noting that
Jonathan
that is true like I said this isn't very
high according to his daily presidential
tracking poll he's doing better than
Barack Obama also a popular president
during that time in his presidency but
many says Trump has lost the
independence which vote says he lost
tell me which votes Donald Trump is lost
because all of the awful predictions
about Donald Trump's handling of the
government have not come true the
opposite has come true record high
economy record high employment
everything is going great peace abroad
relative peace abroad so which votes has
he lost just to use that one it we use
it a lot because after Kanye West came
out people started tracking the vote
among black voters who typically won't
go for Democrats Donald Trump's support
among the black voters has more than
doubled in just eight or nine months
what votes is he lost he hasn't lost any
votes
that's ridiculous wishful thinking the
the lady on MSNBC actually has a right
at the top she was D'Arnot why is he so
popular I go on TV every day and say
he's bad why is he so popular he hasn't
at youth he's had a terrible two week he
hasn't had a terrible two weeks he's at
a great two weeks the Nasdaq broke a
record the Dow broke another record the
S&P I mean ever what are you talking
nobody cares about what you care about
nobody cares a bet well he didn't do and
he should have done this and he didn't
hold his glass there what nobody cares
they care about the economy and peace
abroad and jobs and STFU I mean that is
like that's gonna be the banner I hate
to be vulgar but we're gonna vulgar era
you know and the left especially the
left is being vulgar the right is being
a little vulgar too because it's so
shocking nobody cares about the things
you're pretending to care about the
polls back that up so what is the
response what is the response going to
be because Trump is still popular
despite all the hit jobs
take it away CNN's jeffrey toobin go
ahead let's be clear also about what's
going on here the theme here is I'm
Donny Donald Trump and I'll protect you
from the scary black people and Tifa is
widely perceived as an african-american
organization and this is just part of
the same story of LeBron James and Don
Lemon and Maxine Waters and the NFL
players and the UCLA basketball players
this is about black versus white this is
about Donald Trump's appeal to racism
and it just happens all the time and we
never say it we don't say it enough for
what it is but that's what's going on is
that Jeffrey Toobin nickname for himself
is that were widely perceived his he's
the only person I've ever heard say that
an Tifa is a black organization is
Jeffrey Toobin on CNN nobody says that
in fact it's exactly the opposite there
were all these whiney little white
Communists there are all these shrimpy
little cowardly white communists who put
on napkins over their face one because
they're too cowardly and they don't want
to get arrested and two presumably
because they're very ugly people they're
they're ashamed of that too they hate
themselves no that's ridiculous
but you know nice try Jeffrey it's it
has become ridiculous they I it's so
lovely right they say why is Trump still
popular we've been doing this crooked
investigation and all this insinuation
and lying about stories and know now we
know CNN was lying about a story because
Lanny Davis admits it and this and then
he's still popular you're a racist did
hey guys did that work I caught a cold
Trump a racist do you think that's gonna
work
it's not gonna work that's not gonna
work at all they're doing this to run
DeSantis now not 12 hours after Rhonda
Santas wins his primary in Florida he
went out he was talking about he was
talking about how his opponent it's like
sort of a nice guy
Andrew Gilliam he's the Bernie backed
socialist but he said look don't monkey
this up guys you know don't vote for
socialism but his opponent Andrew
Gilliam is black so now they're saying
he's a racist 12 hours after a key to
all there is but monkey it up or monkey
around these are these are just turns of
phrase these are very popular idioms
there isn't not a shred of evidence that
race has anything to do with that and
but I think this is the game that
Americans are tired of why is Trump's
approval rating so high because of
things like that because in the old days
if someone said monkey it up or monkey
around nobody would think that that was
racist
nobody would actually think that but the
left would pretend it was racist and the
right would pretend that it sounded
racist and then we'd all sort of all he
shouldn't have said that
Oh
no he really like why shouldn't he have
said that not a soul thinks it's racist
we're all just it's all pretend and
Trump comes along and smashes all that
pretense and so now they say is racist
and we're just laughing at them or say
okay yeah okay that's cute keep going on
that one keep going on that one so now
your major pitch to voters this is your
big pitch going into November is racist
racist the final Democrat pitch going
into the midterm elections Don Lemon
give it to me baby
it says it right in the name and Tifa
anti-fascism which is what they were
there fighting listen there's you know
no organization is perfect there was
some violence no one condones of
violence but there were different
reasons for antifa
and for these neo-nazis to be there one
racist fascists the other group fighting
racist fashions there is it a fascist
there's a distinction there so just
because it and something says something
just because the name purports to be one
thing doesn't mean that it's that it is
that right you don't get you this name
yourself McDonald's could name itself
like that
I don't know health foods of America it
doesn't make it health food it makes it
McDonald's it remains McDonald's they
call themselves an tyfa they literally
wear black shirts like like the original
fascist Mussolini's fascists called the
black shirts they go out they wear black
shirts they beat up their political
opponents in the street and they stop
them from speaking they are fascists so
now you've got Democrats have been smart
on this so far they haven't defended an
Tifa because an tyfa or terrorists now
you've got Don Lemon empty-headed Don
Lemon goes out there and starts
defending an tyfa so the argument going
in we've seen these polls last night
we've seen the primaries we can see very
clearly that an important swing states
president Trump's still very popular
this is not surprising we also see that
the Democrat argument is racist and the
final pitch defending an tyfa vote vote
for democrats or will club you on the
head in the street vote for des gonna be
their pitch unbelievable keep it up guys
i hope you do it I keep it up Don Lemon
I want Don Lemon to run for something
get your mailbag questions in because
we've got the mailbag tomorrow in the
meantime I'm Michael Knowles this is the
Michael no
show I'll see you tomorrow
[Music]
the Michael Nolt chin is produced by
seniya Villarreal executive producer
Jeremy bori senior producer Jonathan hey
our supervising producer
Mathis Glover and our technical producer
is austin stevens edited by jim nickel
audio is mixed by mike core amina hair
and makeup is by Joshua alvera the
Michael Noel's show is a daily wire for
word publishing production copyright for
word publishing 2018
you